the new 60 minutes report is revealing
new information about the jail cell
death of convicted sex offender Jeffrey
Epstein the wealthy financier was
accused of sexually abusing dozens of
underage girls
the 66 year old was connected to many
rich and powerful people and his death
left a lot of unanswered questions 60
minutes correspondent Sharon Alfonzo has
investigated Epstein's death for five
months and reveals what happened in the
moments after his body was found guards
found Epstein at approximately 6:30 3:00
a.m. and sources say one of them could
be overheard saying breathe Epstein
breathe forensic pathologist dr. Michael
Baden who observed the autopsy for the
Epstein family believes the Jeffrey
Epstein died around 4:30 that morning
two hours earlier the guards say they
came in at 6:30 they found him they call
emergency services they tried to do CPR
with him but he's dead
but rather than leave the body there
they take the body to an emergency room
yeah is that normal protocol no that
that's not normal protocol the EMS
people normally especially in jail
should not move a dead body he's right
Bureau of prison protocol mandates a
suicide scene should be treated with the
same level of protection as any crime
scene in which a death has occurred
Sharon Alfonzo is with us now Sharon
welcome what did the prison guards do
with Jeffrey Epstein's body so
immediately after they discovered him
they took him to the hospital they were
trying to do CPR on him about an hour
after he got to the hospital they
declared him officially dead about 7:30
and then it seemed the morgue where they
did the autopsy the next day what do we
know about what was found in Jeffrey
Epstein's jail cell so it's interesting
you would think that it would be sparse
right this is a federal prison
high-security what we have learned
through our reporting is that there was
multiple sheets and there lots of
bedding an electrical cord prescription
medicine
there was actually notes and a paper he
had written a note
and on Sunday we'll show you what that
note said so in the piece you were heard
saying that a guard was saying breathe
Jeffrey breathe so this was widely known
what was happening in the prison or - we
aren't sure well we know the way that
the prison was set up he was in a secure
area where there were about eight cells
and so we have heard and our sources
tell us that the guards could be
overheard saying breathe epstein breathe
and what's kind of eerie is that after
that the prisoners that were in that
secure area all started chanting breathe
epstein breathe so the prison they were
the prisoners other prisoners were aware
of what was going on something was going
on it's you know the doors are blocked
they probably couldn't see that much but
certainly they heard the commotion was
there video surveillance in there and in
that area it's a great question we know
that there was video surveillance facing
the guards desk which is outside of the
area where he was we are told that the
video facing the cells the video that
might have seen his cell door was
corrupted it was interrupted meaning we
don't know okay good question so on the
question of what was in his jail cell I
mean it's interesting you what expects
it to be Spartan apparently it wasn't
but was that a violation there in that
cell I mean was it it was it unusual to
find bedsheets er there's very specific
Bureau of prison protocol about what's
allowed inside a cell and I think you'll
see on Sunday when you see the photos
that a lot of the bedding raises a lot
of questions as you know it had been
reported that he made a first failed
suicide attempt weeks earlier and yet
his cell was covered in bedding in
sheets he was the only person in the
cell and there were enough sheets for
lots of people why was she there at that
point in time all right Sharon all fancy
thank you very much
you